growth involves leverage leverage means
more people
the amount of money you earn is in
direct ratio to the need for what you do
your ability to do it and the difficulty
there is in replacing you
how you think about money will have a
significant impact
on your financial future and also on
your decision making
[Music]
i'm going to show you a bunch of
different ways to do the math people
that haven't done the math are basically
irresponsible
if you've never done the math
do the math on any number if you've
never done the math
you are basically an irresponsible
person financially okay and if you're
irresponsible
you don't have money if you don't have
money you're irresponsible they're tied
together i promise you
when i didn't have money it's because i
was irresponsible i operated
irresponsibly
i acted irresponsibly grabbed my phone
real quick
so i'm going to show you a bunch of
different ways i want you to figure out
every different way you can get to a
million dollars
every possible way to a million dollars
okay here's one way
okay and and i laid some of this out
earlier
in the webcast i laid this out
million dollar math fifty thousand
dollars twenty years
that's a million dollars a hundred
thousand dollars times ten years
that's a million dollars two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for four years
that's a million dollars a hundred and
fourteen dollars an
hour every hour 365 days of the year
24 hour 24 7 365. by the way notice what
my
my plate says 365 gc that's all i wanted
money for
i wanted to be me 365 days of the year
if i could earn a hundred and fourteen
dollars an hour
for 87 hours
yeah 8 760 hours
times 114 dollars every hour
i earn a million dollars in a year let
me show you some other ways to do this
if i could get 5 000 people
to give me 200 bucks that's a million
dollars
if i could get 2 000 people
to give me five hundred dollars that's a
million dollars now my question is back
to this
you need to believe in the possibility
and you need to believe in me not in you
is this possible are there 5 000 people
on this planet is there 8 760 hours in a
year
are there 2 000 people on this planet
are there 2 000 people that have 500
bucks okay
or i could do this i could get 500
people
to give me 2 000 that's a million
dollars see now i did this math robert's
like dude i get
are there 500 people on planet earth
that could give you two thousand dollars
absolutely so when you're saying oh my
god everybody's broke nobody's got money
the world's coming to an end
are there 500 people that have two
thousand dollars
the bank asked me i moved from houston
to to uh
laurier california and i bought a house
in la jolla and the and the
the banker was like i borrowed money for
a house this is when i was buying houses
stupid and the banker said well dude how
are you going to move over here and make
money i'm like bro
okay what's the payment he told me i
said good
do the math are there 500 people on this
planet that will make that payment
sure i've been doing that for years you
understand i do the math on the banker
okay or you need 300 people
to give you 3 33 a month
i can keep doing this math or i could
get 5 000 people to pay me 17
a month so how many different ways can
you do the math
how many different ways can you do the
math
[Music]
okay these are not my checks these
checks came from other people this is
not my money it's my money now
how long can i keep it can i economize
my energy can i
economize my creativity am i focused on
collecting money
okay do you deserve to be a millionaire
do you are you really committed to being
rich
and is being rich worth more than being
poor is it easier to get rich
in your lifetime than it is to stay poor
for a lifetime when i made that decision
everything changed how about this
what if i could get 5 000 people
to give me 17 a month
that by the way is one million dollars
what if i could get two thousand people
maybe this would be easier
to give me forty two dollars a month
or a thousand people to pay me eighty
three dollars a month or
you understand 500 people to give me 167
a month or what if i could just simply
get 300 people
to give me 278 dollars a month
now when i look at this i'm like why
don't i get 5 000 people to pay me 200
2 000 people to pay me 500 1 000 people
to pay me 1 000
500 to pay me 2 000 and now i'm making
10 million here
you understand why not why not do all of
them okay again back to the point what's
the point
how do you stay sold the questions we're
getting from people is dude how do i
stay
in the deal how do i make a commitment
and
it stays stuck okay this is how you do
it
remember two parts mental
one part mechanical this is where you
need
it's mental right i write about this
every day
every day i write
i write okay i'm highly connected
to the mission every day it's in my face
you're a threat grant
you can't help your community you can't
make a difference
now my difference is actually not money
okay
i want 1 billion people many of you have
heard me talk about 7 billion
actually i only want 1 billion i need 7
billion 7 billion to know my name
so i can do a business with a billion of
them i want to help a billion people i
don't think there's actually seven
billion people that want to be helped on
this planet
i think there's maybe a billion people
that want to be helped i help a billion
people i'd rather have a billion friends
than a billion dollars because if i have
a billion friends
you know the old adage about a boat
what's the best boat tone
the best boat to have is somebody else's
boat let them pay for the boat i want a
friend with a boat i want a friend with
a plane
right i need a billion people so if i
can help a billion people
do better am i good is my family good
sure it is okay it's not who you know
it's not
it's not always what you know it's who
you know i need the people on this
planet to have prosperity abundance
connections
and help okay so do the math do the math
stay connected to the mental okay write
about it every day
hook up with people that are thinking
about this okay get the right group
around you
and then reinforce reinforce the
activity daily that's why our online
platform is so important
i got to reinforce skills to get to that
money
keep in mind that when i started doing
this i had no money i was 25 years old i
didn't own a real estate company okay i
didn't have checks coming in
there was none of this i'm in car sales
in lake charles louisiana
in a town this big nobody around me made
more than 40 grand nobody okay
i don't think the owner of the company
made more than 400 grand in a year no
nobody talked about money
my mother didn't know about money so
what did i have to do
okay hey i need to start writing about
what i'm doing i'm gonna make 100 grand
my first
my first thing was this i'm gonna make
100 grand a month i'm sorry 100 grand a
year
my first step was to go from 30 to 100.
how do i do that
write about it every day get in the
right group start collecting data there
was no right group for me everybody
where i live was a bunch of morons
literally there was no intelligence
surrounding me
okay it was morons everywhere i looked
drinking beer
eating crawfish throwing back tequila
cheap tequila too cherry vodka on the
weekends
so i had to get a new group there was no
group so what did i do i got audio
programs video programs books
my group became people i never met
and then i reinforced that every day
anytime you can be at six figures you
got something going on you're solving a
problem for somebody
and they're willing to pay you for it
how do you grow it
that's basically his question this is a
big decision
and i'll tell you why growth involves
leverage leverage means more people you
have to start to manage
people now some people are really good
at it and others aren't
this is a skill set that either you are
born with or you have to learn very
quickly because
in growing a business you have to draw
new talent in
particularly it sounds like in chris's
case to get more sales
so you've got to find great sales people
you have to motivate them sales is a
very hard job
and you have to manage them and you have
to manage the business at the same time
and that my friends is what
entrepreneurship is all about
i say to chris because he's got a
business and he's got six figures and he
wants to get to seven is go for it buddy
go for it now is your life gonna be more
fun and easier than last year
no it's to get much harder but that's
why they call it work
is it worth it oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's definitely worth it most people
think they want more money than they
really do
and they settle for a whole lot less
than they could get
let's look at money for a moment look at
this
that's not money do you know what that
is that's a piece of paper
that's been published by the american
government
and they call it money it just
represents money
money is an idea that's what it is
it's a reward we see for service renters
the more of it you have the more you can
do
see money isn't going to make you a
better person that's one 100 dollar bill
now look here for a moment here's a
hundred
100 dollar bills i got it all bundled up
here
that's a hundred of them this
or this is not going to make me a better
person having this does make me a better
person enough
i had this i can do more with this than
i can with this
money is an instrument now let's suppose
i'm going to feed hungry people
i can feed more people with this than i
can with this
so that would make me more effective and
that's what money does
money is an instrument it enables you to
extend the service you render far beyond
your own physical presence
and that's really what it's used for
it's an instrument
and it can be earned and you can earn
all the money you want all the money in
the universe is available to you
but you've got to earn it do you know
what you want to do you want to take
your pen
and sit down and write down how much you
want to earn
and then understand this earn is the
operative word here you must earn it
nobody's going to give it to you and you
earn it by providing service
now i have found the more service you
render
the more money you can earn it's that
simple
i earn a lot of money at what i do
because
guaranteed by law we're supposed to earn
a lot of money
see the amount of money you earn is
always in direct ratio to the need for
what you do
your ability to do it and the difficulty
there is in replacing you
the need for what you do there's a
tremendous need for what i do all over
the world
we teach people how to understand
themselves how to understand the natural
laws that govern this universe of which
they are apart
how to improve the results they're
getting in their life how to be more
effective how to build their company how
to build themselves
we teach people information that's not
taught in school
it's needed everywhere in the world i've
worked in shanghai i've worked in kosovo
and boniceros
in kota canabulu i've worked all over
the world and anywhere i've gone
they want what i've got i've got a
process that shows people how to develop
the infinite potential they've got
within themselves
and when they do that they earn more
money i'm frequently asked
what would you do if you were starting
over i'd be a network marketer i think
that's one of the most phenomenal ways
to earn money
see the secret of earning a lot of money
is have multiple sources of income
you don't have one you have many sources
of income
do you know as a network marketer you
could have thousands of sources of
income
now one thousands you can earn more
money when you're sleeping
than you can when you're awake eric
worry put something out he's a great
network marketer probably one of the
best in the world
yeah but he trains people how to do it
and how to do it effectively
he said it isn't what works that makes
the difference
it's what you can duplicate that makes a
difference so what you do
it's how you teach other people to do
what you do
so it's not what you do that works it's
what duplicate
that's what works money is a reward
receiver service render
the amount of money you earn is directly
to the need for what you do
is there a need for teaching people how
to earn money
how to build their business how to build
themselves how to change the results
it's a screaming need all over the world
that's what i do
so it's the need for what you do then
your ability to do it now i've got very
good at it
because i've done it for a long time but
not because i've done it for a long time
a lot of people do things for a long
time but they never get really good at
it
they have one year experience 50 times i
study every day there's not a day goes
by
that i do not study that i don't work at
improving me
because i know when i stop working at
improving me i'm going to stop
improving when i started stop improving
i go in the wrong direction
you see a basic law of life says create
or disintegrate you're either going one
way or another
so it's the need for what you do your
ability to do it i want to get better at
this
i don't want to be good at it i want to
be better milt campbell a great friend
of mine
won the decathlon the in the olympics
he said good better best never let it
rest until the good's better
until the better's best that's the way
you want to work now the third
part of this process for
the law of earning money or the law of
prosperity love compensation
is a very simple one it's the difficulty
there is in replacing you
so it's a need for what you do your
ability to do it and then the difficulty
there isn't replacing you
when you become really good at what
you're doing you're going to be very
difficult to replace
now the prison is difficult to replace
that person's stock goes up
do you want to earn a lot of money you
can earn all these you want
it's all available to you the only
person that's holding you back is you
earn a lot of money provide a lot of
service fall in love with what you do
and get better at it now do you know a
good rule to follow
go to someone that understands that
you're doing better than you know it
and then do exactly what they tell you
don't think you know more than them
understand they do know more than you
not everybody but some people
pick the ones that do and then do
exactly what they tell you
remember money is earned
according to the law of compensation the
law of compensation is clear
the amount of money you earn is in
direct ratio to the need for what you do
your ability to do it and the difficulty
there is in replacing you
become really difficult to replace how
you think about
money will have a significant impact
on your financial future and also on
your decision making
since childhood think back how do you
view about money
when you first got a few dollars
why you won that first few dollars what
did you do with
that money maybe you bought candy with
it
maybe you bought that toy maybe then
later on
you would buy a little bicycle right or
maybe you would treat yourself
to a hamburger the poor and the middle
class and the rich
we all have very different views on
money
mike tyson for example one of the most
formidable boxers of all time now at the
time
mike tyson was earning a lot of money in
fact
hundreds hundreds of millions
of dollars but later on he went bankrupt
not only he spent all of that money
hundreds of millions of dollars
he later on was actually in debt and
owing money
owing taxes
why now the problem is you may be
thinking oh he just spends money no
that's not the problem the root of the
problem is
mike tyson at the time has a certain
view
on money that caused that behavior
and now mike tyson is bouncing back he
has bounced back
in movies and now he's worth you know a
few million dollars again
i have a lot of respect for mike in fact
at my house i have a
signed autograph glove by mike tyson
so money how do you view money now if
you're like most people when you think
about money
you think about how am i going to spend
it
what am i going to buy that's one belief
system
if you want to accumulate wealth if you
want to
actually create wealth we need to have a
different point of view
one of the most powerful shifts that you
can make
today is stop thinking about
what money can buy and start thinking
what money can earn i'll say that one
more time
stop thinking what money can buy
and start thinking what money can earn
think of money as a golden goose that
lays
golden eggs when you spend it that money
is gone
forever it disappears nowhere to be
found
and then you need to earn new money to
replace that
but you think about what money can earn
you will think about money very very
differently
how you would use that hundred dollar
bill and don't think more money will
solve the problem if you do not know how
to use
a hundred dollar wisely what makes you
think you know how to use
a thousand dollar wisely what makes you
think you know how to use
ten thousand dollar wisely and what
makes you think you know how to use
a hundred thousand dollar wisely the
world is
filled with athletes and doctors and
lawyers and
entrepreneurs and high income
professionals who earn a lot of money
yet they
are broke because they have a broken
view
on money that is what is causing
the problem it is not the money itself
is their
point of view on money now i'm not
asking you to be cheap and i'm not
asking you to live life in scarcity what
i'm asking you is
to look at it differently maybe you
could put
this hundred dollar bill into an index
fund
that generates on average eight to ten
percent return
over a long period of time let the
miracle of compound interest
to work for you maybe you would use this
hundred dollar bill
to take a successful person out to lunch
and you buy that person lunch
and you seek knowledge and ask good
questions
or maybe you would use this hundred
dollar bill to
join toastmasters to improve your
communication skill
so you become a more confident speaker
or maybe you use this hundred dollar
bill to
buy a group of books a bunch of books so
you could
accumulate and acquire more knowledge so
you would be
smarter you will be more intelligent the
same hundred dollar bill
cash is trash in other words you
it looks like a low risk thing to hold
but it's not
because when because when you have a
zero interest rate or in some cases in
foreign countries slightly negative
interest rate
and you have an inflation rate of two
percent or higher
you get taxed at a rate essentially you
lose buying power
at a rate of about two percent a year
and that's a lot you lose a lot of
buying power
and so this is one of those environments
you don't want to hold
cash if anything maybe you borrow some
cash
and find something that has better than
a zero interest rate in it or
that or something that has inflation if
you bought the average
thing which is inflation at two percent
or more a year
you'd be better off however you uh
so the other thing you need to do is
diversify well
okay so don't have cash and
then you need diversification and the
diversification
should be currency diversification
country diversification
as well as asset class diversification
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
percent
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you the richest man
in babylon said
save 10 of everything that you make so
for every 10
coins that you make save one and
that served him well and in general that
served me well it's still something that
i actually
live by when when nina and i do our
monthly numbers of how much we made
we will save 10 and put it towards
different investments that we're making
right now
and most of the investments we're making
aren't in the business most of the
investments we're making
are into uh either angel investments
that i'm doing or
public markets right stocks and index
funds
i look at that advice though and i think
when i was getting started i don't know
how much that would serve me
being 100 honest and this might fly in
the face of a lot of
typical financial advice but i think
back to when i was first getting started
and i was making 300 bucks a month
if i saved 30 bucks out of the 300 bucks
i don't know that i am where i am
every dollar was being stretched as far
as i could go right i had a
20 or 25 dollar monthly budget to spend
hanging out with my friends to have
pizza and beer and
whatever i had to say note almost
everything because
i was yes too embarrassed and too
ashamed to tell my friends that i was
struggling
and so that one thing a month that i
would do with them
meant a lot and if i had to cancel that
out to save it
i feel like i would have quit on the
business a lot sooner
i don't know that i stick with the
company maybe i do
and maybe it all works out but i
remember how
every single dollar that came in
meant so much meant
so much that i couldn't imagine
giving up 10 and just staying with the
business
i honestly think i would have quit
sooner
and gone and got a job and i think that
might be the difference is well
where are you spending not just your
money but your time i was
spending my time trying to build my
company i was spending much
time investing into my future not just
some dead-end job that i hated
i think if you have some crappy job and
you're not spending your time
doing anything to build a brighter
future then yes then
your money that you're saving helps you
build a brighter future but i i
think people discount too much the the
investment of time to become an
entrepreneur and i'm
i'm investing more than 10 of my time
to try to make this business work once i
started making some money then it's a
lot easier it's it's easier to put 10
of your money away when you're making
money when
you're not making anything and you need
that money to survive
right the richest man in babylon also
had a
great lesson around really understanding
the difference between your needs and
your wants what do you actually need
versus what do you just want right i
don't i don't need to have a porsche
i didn't need to spend eight hundred
dollars to get
custom seat belts right
ridiculous i just really wanted the red
seat belts so so they get these four
seat belts there was a five way how many
we got
one two three this one here four or five
five seat belts cost me 800 something
dollars
that's a that's a want it's not a need i
don't need to be in this car
i don't need to have these seat belts
but when i was first starting my company
there were no wants right it was all
need
300 bucks doesn't go very far everything
was neat
and so i think if a hundred percent of
your budget is truly right like let's
not kid ourselves it's truly going
towards needs
what you need to survive and i think if
you're spending your time trying to
build your business
or trying to create a brighter future
for yourself i think that's okay
i think that's okay and i think as soon
as you start making money
then you invest it and i'm even okay
with investing it back into your
business it might be
riskier i mean it is riskier
compared to investing in something else
but i'd rather bet on myself
than facebook or then amazon
or then the us economy right like i'd
just rather bet on myself
i think betting on yourself has the
highest upside
[Music]
now when you're making a lot of money or
when you get past the point of happiness
right um there's a famous
i think it was princeton study that said
once you're making 75k
a year there's no difference in your
happiness level
you could be making 75k a year you can
be making 80 million a year and your
happiness level is basically the same
but up to 75 000 money can buy happiness
[Music]
the ability to have food to eat you know
the ability to
afford health care the ability to have a
car
you know money can buy happiness up to
75 000
a year so that's
you and you're on your way there
or everything that you're spending money
on right now is actually
a need for you and your family to
survive
and you're spending your time investing
in your business trying to build a
brighter future for yourself i'm
actually okay with
putting everything into your company at
least it worked for me
you know it worked for me and i and i
really believed that if i
had saved that money great so i'm saving
30 bucks a month
what is that gonna what is that going to
do for me
[Music]
now if i had again a job that i hated
and i had no prospects of making a
brighter future for myself the money
creates the prospect to create a
better future for myself but if you're
an entrepreneur and you're building up
i think it's i think it's great to put
in on yourself
i really do um and then once you're
making money
invest it back into yourself invest it
back into your business if you know what
to invest in
and if you don't then you invest it into
other things
and i'm i'm the guy who's who's now
following that advice
right i'm investing into other companies
i'm investing into public markets i'm
investing into
index funds i'm saving 10 of what i'm
making
but it's easy for me now to do that
i just try to put myself back into the
shoes of me 19 starting
do you know why they tell you to save
money
i don't know
because the system of banking york
is nothing to do with communism or
capitalism
it's the banks run the world the rich
run the world
they don't care your communism
capitalist
so when you save so let's say you save
one dollar you as a one euro one yen
the banking system can lend out 10.
so the entire system is called the
fractional reserve
system the fractional reserve system is
also
printing money and then they tell you to
save money so they
they want you to save money so they can
lend out your money 10 times
so your dollar became worthless 10 times
over
and then they used to pay you 10
interest on your money now it's at best
one percent
and they're still lending it out 10
times so that's why you don't save money
is because your money is becoming worth
less and less and less and less unless
the banks are getting richer and richer
and richer
then they tax you on that interest you
they pay you that one percent interest
if they pay you that much
japan is zero and the japanese associate
they still save money
we also have zero yeah and they still
save money
what is that so that's what i question
so how come that happens
now if i borrow money guess what do i
pay taxes on debt
i guess no why is that
i know this is this is what i'm saying
okay question
everything okay so when they lend out
money
that's how money is created money is
debt
they lend out them why is debt tax free
i don't know because that's how money is
created
and so the banks love it they love
people borrow lots of money
so how do i get rich i borrow money
and i buy assets with it the poor person
borrows money and buys liabilities like
purses
cars houses and they get poorer and
poorer and poorer
but i use debt i borrowed 300 million
after the crash dollars in 2000
by 2010 i had borrowed 300 million
dollars to buy real estate
that made me rich and the interest rates
kept coming down so my cost of money
kept coming down
hence everybody else is saying oh you
should get out of debt you know why
because they don't question the hypnosis
they're under
you've been hypnotized to work hard for
money
to save it the fractional reserve system
prints it and then
you pay taxes of taxes so i get i have
all this debt
and i get rich so the question is how do
you learn to use
debt to get rich tom tried to be
the best be the first
be the first to change be the first
to take the challenge be the first
one to overcome the difficulties
because the best person there's only one
olympic
champion i don't think i'm lucky enough
to be that
but i can always try the new things and
don't give i
believe it because you you are so unique
everybody is unique
be yourself is always the key right now
kathy your etfs alone
are generating an annualized run rate of
220 million dollars in revenue and that
doesn't include
the other assets under management um
how profitable is the business
well it has our business
is uh very profitable now but believe me
the blood sweat and tears that we left
in the early days it's a scalable model
so we had to pay for the infrastructure
in the early days
and we were quite the loss making
company
and i felt it acutely since i i funded
uh most of it for the first three years
uh
and so but in those early days we were
investing aggressively
which is what we tell our companies to
do because we thought we would be able
to scale and when we were
and when we were able to scale we'd have
the right talent in place
uh to scale and so we've done that
and uh and i'm very happy to say
that we are able to reward uh those who
are making
us happen the team that's making this
happen um
and rightfully so so uh in a way the
the hedge fund model you have uh
maybe fewer people and
uh less in the way of assets uh
and the same kind of profits uh so we've
done it a different way
uh and now we've shown it's possible and
uh
uh and and we think it's a really
healthy way to go as well
there's a kind of a right time to kind
of enter uh
a segment you know and if you look back
in history it's kind of interesting how
things happen in in groups so like if
you look back to you mentioned
mcdonald's before
mcdonald's burger king wendy's kentucky
fried chicken all started within
uh you know the similar years why is
that why did fast food
happen then why did you know target and
kmart and walmart all start around the
same time
like it's because there are trends in
society baby
that makes yeah that make that make
businesses
you know be the right time and as an
entrepreneur if you're thinking about
like
you're open to doing anything there's
two different kinds there's there's i
have this
passion in this area and i know this
area well
and i think i can do it better great
then follow that passion if you don't
have necessarily a passion
and you just say i really want to start
a business i'm excited i want to be an
entrepreneur
and looking the first thing i would say
is look
broadly at sort of the world and see
where the where the the mega trends
happening um and then and and get into
a moving train you know get on a moving
train because that's the easiest way to
to raise capital is to is to get on on a
trend that's already
already sort of in motion my job one of
my jobs
as the leader of amazon is to encourage
people to be bold and people love to
focus on things that aren't yet working
and that's good it's human nature that
kind of divine discontent can be very
helpful
but you really you know it's incredibly
hard to get people to take bold bets
and you need to encourage that and if
you're going to take bold bets
they're going to be experiments and if
they're experiments you don't know ahead
of time whether they're going to work
experiments are by their very nature
prone to failure but big successes a few
big successes
compensate for dozens and dozens of
things that didn't work
so you know bold bets aws kindle
amazon prime our third-party seller
business
all of those things are examples of bold
bets that
uh that that did work and they pay for a
lot of experiments
i've made billions of dollars of
failures
at amazon.com literally billions of
dollars of failures
and uh you know you might remember
pets.com or cosmo or
you know give myself a root canal with
no anesthesia very easily
none of those things are fun but but
they also
they don't matter what really matters is
companies that don't
continue to experiment companies that
don't embrace
failure they eventually get in a
desperate position
where they the only thing they can do is
make a kind of hail mary bet at the very
end of their corporate existence
whereas companies that are you know
making bets all along even you know big
bets but not bet the company bets
i don't i don't believe in bet the
company bets that's when you're
desperate
that's that's the last thing you can do
everyone thinks that spanx actually
started when i cut the feed out of my
pantyhose but the truth is it started
many many years before that
it started when i was selling fax
machines door-to-door
getting kicked out of office buildings
day in and day out
and i woke up one morning and i thought
i'm in the wrong movie
how did this happen this is not my life
cut scene call the director call the
producer
no and i took out a piece of paper and i
wrote down what i was good at
and there was not much on the page the
word
i saw the word sales i knew i was good
in sales so i wrote down
in my journal i want to invent a product
that i can sell to millions of people
that will make them feel good
and then i asked the universe for an
idea
and i waited for two years and the idea
showed up
and the minute i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose i decided to pursue it
so what do you do when you have an idea
and you've never
taken a business class or worked in
fashion or retail
i wanted to patent my idea and
i ended up looking for a female patent
attorney
and i called the georgia chamber of
commerce
and they said there actually wasn't a
single female patent attorney in the
entire state of georgia
so i looked in the yellow pages and
found three men's name and
went out and pitched my idea to them and
they actually thought the idea was so
bad that one of the patent lawyers later
admitted to me he thought i'd been sent
by candid camera
which makes sense because he was looking
around the room for the hidden cameras
but
he ended up eventually helping me i went
to barnes noble bought a book on patents
and trademarks wrote my own patent
and went back to him and said please
please will you just write the claims
portion of it and
he did for a discounted price but it
makes me think about inventors and
innovators and when you hear those words
do you think of women
last year my son had inventor
week at his school and they asked me to
come and be the keynote speaker
at his kindergarten class
so i was the inventor that was coming
and i started out looking at all these
cute little kids and i said
so what does an inventor look like and
all their hands shot up and one kid said
it's a man and he has crazy hair and
somebody else raised her in and said no
no it's a bald man
no it's a tall man it's a short man and
i just stopped and i said
well i'm an inventor and their eyes got
really big and they said you
are and it dawned on me i looked around
the room and all the
pictures of inventors were albert
einstein thomas edison steve jobs so
i can see why the the young girl who
asked me and said i didn't know girls
could be inventors was surprised
and even my son on the way home he goes
mom you're an inventor but
the real point of all of this was i
wanted to help women and i'm so
passionate about it
and it's amazing that i started with
their butts and i've continued to groan
i started at the sarah blakely
foundation because i truly believe
that the world would be a much better
place if the male and female energy on
the planet was more balanced
as we surveyed our employees every one
of them
were looking for a purpose something in
life
that made them feel good about the
company remember we don't make
life-saving drugs
we don't provide technology that changes
your life we make fun
products so we wanted to give people a
real purpose
why coming to work at pepsico was the
greatest thing
so what we did is we said why don't we
make the shifting of the portfolio
offering more nutritious products
offering more grains offering more fruit
and vegetable offerings
really becoming an environmentally
conscious company
and creating an environment in pepsico
where everybody can bring their whole
self to work
part of the agenda as to how we make
money not how we spend the money how we
make money
and that got encapsulated in these three
words performance with purpose
it all starts with performance we want
to deliver the greatest financial
returns
but we want to deliver those profits
while
we transform our product portfolio worry
about the planet
and worry about our people and that was
simply performance with purpose
and the fundamental difference between
corporate social responsibility and
performance with purpose is that
performance with purposes is about how
we make the money
not how we spend the money that we make
so if we don't transform our portfolio
we cannot make profits
if we're not environmentally sustainable
we won't get a license to open a plant
and we won't reduce the cost of our
packaging and if we don't create a
phenomenal workplace for our people
we won't be able to hire the best and
the brightest so we
our purpose became how we deliver the
profit
the idea you start with uh
it didn't work but it's a starting point
but once you start you actually begin
learning
what might be the path to something that
will work
i mean in netflix's case it took a long
time but
it doesn't mean that it's not a fun
process or that it's a
it's a process in itself you're actually
moving forward even though you know you
haven't figured it out yet
i mean certainly when we started netflix
was not streaming video
it was dvd it was mailing dvds and for
those people who might actually
be familiar with the netflix dvd service
now it wasn't like it is now
it wasn't a subscription service it was
due dates it was late fees
i mean it was looking back on it
ridiculous
and so of course it didn't work i mean
the occasional person would rent from us
but they wouldn't rent a second time
it was really hard to find someone who
was willing to do it more than once
but we learned we tried things we tested
things
and each time you do a test even though
it may not solve the problem completely
it does illuminate the path forward just
a little bit
at the very least you've learned what
doesn't work and you can try a different
direction
and little by little in our case it took
a year
and a half but eventually you finally if
you're lucky stumble onto the business
model
that actually does work that's
repeatable
and scalable and where you can actually
lo and behold
charge more for it than it costs you to
deliver the service
when i was 32 33
maybe 34 somewhere in that range i was
really frustrated because
i love what i do for a living it's
emotional rewards are gigantic
but it's not a it's not a business that
has a great deal of
you know opportunity for maximizing
profit because this is a low margin
business
and i didn't get into it's like what's
the best business get in is this i'm an
artist i want to help people change
their lives this is my this is my
mission
so you know we were in the 9 10
margin and doesn't take much of a
challenge when your margin is that small
to have a real challenge in your
business
so i called a group of billionaire
friends of mine that i've coached over
the years and i always want to be the
giver i never asked for anything but i
said to them look i have these
seven or eight opportunities that are
being put in front of me that look
incredible
i still want to run my core business but
i'd love to get your coaching
i've coached you guys would you be
willing to coach me just for a couple
hours so i brought them all here in new
york
had this incredible meeting i'll never
forget and i decided
i wanted to add value so i introduced
them to each other they all knew of each
other they're all kings of the titans of
business some
some were friends and then i said so let
me show you the good the bad the ugly of
my story and so i told them my
entrepreneurial story from the very
beginning
no money the ups and downs the
near-death experiences
and i was watching their eyes get this
big because a lot of them they didn't
start businesses like that right some of
them started businesses by
getting a billion dollar loan one guy
right he was able to do because
it's financial backing and so i can see
them getting more and more intense and
long story short at the end they're like
stop stop stop you shouldn't do any of
these opportunities they're all
wonderful opportunities you've got to go
back and maximize your business you have
to maximize your business
and one of the guys had just been to one
of my seminars when i unleash the power
within seminar and he told
me came up to me tony the most
incredible thing i've ever done in my
life because tony you work
so hard you're on stage 12 14 hours a
day i don't know how you hold people's
attention people won't sit for a
two-hour movie three-hour movie
and you got people so you're never going
to want to do this when you're like 42
you know because that's like 32. same
guy three weeks later goes you're not
working hard enough on your business i'm
like what the heck
and what it was was they all reacted
because they're used to a different type
of business
and one of the guys afterwards says hey
i was near tears
because i walked in thinking on the
greatest business opportunities in the
world and i walk back feeling like i'm a
piece of you know what right
and one of the guys billionaire says to
me he goes hey tony where are you
staying
at the four seasons he goes i'm staying
there too three blocks away can i walk
with you i want to get your advice
on something i thought who me dumbass
i'm the one you want this advice from
right
and he says to me i'll never forget he
goes tony he owned for the
underwear company he goes up i got an
offer
make me about a billion nine
so i kind of i gotta decide do i do i
sell the company
do i build it up bigger and then sell it
or do i keep it for my son
and i said i said bill i said i love you
to death i said you already know the
answer you just you want me to confirm
it for you let's be honest
i said first of all if you sell the
company now get a billion eight billion
nine more it's not going to change your
life one iota
you have the planes the cars the homes
the all that stuff plenty of cash
i'm not going to change but if you sell
when the business is not
at its peak you'll resent yourself later
on you'll you'll be mad because you're a
guy that loves to maximize he goes oh
you're so right
and i said keeping it for your son he's
five right
does he want to be the underwear king i
don't think so i said go build it a
little bit more to the level you know it
is and then sell it
right and he goes oh my god it's so
brilliant so great but what i got on
this conversation that changed my life
was
i hated it i felt they didn't understand
and they didn't understand a bunch
but i said there's got to be some truth
in there and then i saw this
uh story about this guy who spent
i think it was 17 years looking for the
spanish galleon
his name was mel i'm playing a last name
but it was very famous in the 1990s 80s
and he literally made no money found
nothing
like 16 years into it he had to convince
people to give him more money
one of his members his crew died it was
the most brutal approach
how could you possibly keep going out
there
looking for treasure and not finding it
for five years
not giving up or 10 16. i think he went
18 if i remember correctly
and he found a half a billion dollars
with the gold
so i asked myself a question i said
what would make a guy go 16 17 18 years
with no evidence of success and keep
doing and convince people to give him
money and keep going working seven day
weeks
he'd have to believe something different
than other people what would he have to
believe
and i thought first you'd have to
believe the treasure's there
i didn't believe the treasure was in my
business so you didn't find it
right second you'd have to believe i
will find it
and third to go that many years you'd
have to believe it's worth it
and i shifted those three beliefs in my
business and i cr
things i once i committed completely to
that business and nothing else
i grew the business like crazy and i
ended up selling half that business for
200 million dollars the business that
looked like it would never make
anything when i did that i said now i'm
a successful entrepreneur
now i'll take on some other companies
because i'm not bsing myself i've really
built it
this idea you're gonna go build nine
companies nice ego stroke
no way you can give them the focus that
you need but today i can do more with my
pinky
than i used to be able to do work in 20
hour days because i know more people i
have more contacts i have more strategy
i have more tools
and so you've got to make sure you
maximize something and really make a
real business you want to know your real
test
could you sell the business tomorrow for
a significant multiple if not don't
start another business
or get rid of his business sell it and
start something fresh
but most people are always looking for
what's easier and it always looks easier
what you really want to do is maximize
the business you're in
what is your thing and when did you kind
of understand what it was it hasn't
changed my thing is
learning learning whatever is new and
applying it in ways that other people
aren't thinking of and so when i started
i got fired from a job selling software
started a company
and within six months this is the early
days of pcs i recognized that okay
we need to connect pcs together back
then you walked around you had your 500
quarter inch floppy and you know who
would need to connect to pc
we started you know writing software for
local area networks became a systems
integrator
30 some million dollar run rate and sold
it to um h r block
and then got to the internet okay let's
look at this internet thing
someone's going to need to put audio and
then video on there great and then after
yahoo did yahoo
right i'm like you know what i'm looking
at these big screen tvs that cost
thirty thousand dollars that are high
definition television sets
and i'm thinking you know what
eventually they're gonna follow the
price performance curve
of traditional of traditional um
consumer electronics
and they're going to come down to price
so i started the first all high
definition tv network called hdnet
then i'm looking and saying okay you
know what it's like 2006 2007
and traditional television and cable is
going um digital
i'm saying you know what there's going
to be more a lot of storage space than
first access digital space
that cable companies aren't used to
using so let's take
a movie production company that we
created and
let's make it available for day and date
distribution where people can will pay
20 bucks um to the the cable company to
watch this brand new movie
and we get to keep 10 of it and so we
had 29 29 productions we started
producing movies
and lo and behold the first movie we
created was a documentary called enron
the smartest guys in the room
got nominated for academy award then we
didn't really create any good ones after
that but
by being first leveraging digital
storage we were able to take advantage
and make a lot of money
and in the mba with the mavericks you
know just doing those types of things
and it's what i like to do now
you're a runner with a track coach that
you're very fond of
an accountant and a stanford business
school grad oh
that produced a crazy idea how did it
come to you well it was a combination of
two things it came off the running track
at oregon and out of the
the classroom at the stanford business
school and uh
that barman was always tinkering with
shoes and
uh he began to have some of his good
runners not just his hacks like me
you know where where the shoes and they
were wearing them quite successfully and
he was very
sincere in believing the weight of the
shoe was very important to a runner and
so that registered
then uh all of all the best shoes were
being made in germany it made no sense
that you would make shoes adidas and
puma
make no sense that they'd be made in
germany so i wrote the paper about uh
they should make them in japan and
uh the idea built and built and built
and it became a crazy idea to
everybody but me and my college
professor and then my old track coach
i'm 15 pounds overweight my doctor said
and he said you know if you wanted to be
in perfect health which everything else
is perfect my health i'm
i'm well you should lose 15 pounds and i
said i'd have to give up three or four
martinis and a bottle of wine every
night
i'm not willing to do that it's i know
what it takes and i know what i have to
do
i used to run marathons i run the boston
marathon and i know what it
took to train and i'm not you know i
don't run
like that anymore i stare master but i
mean i
we all know how to lose weight we all
know how to get physically fit
we all know how to build our businesses
i can go to the yellow pages today and
pick out any business that's in this
room
and i can find somebody that's beating
your brains out
i don't care what you do
and as some of you heard me say but i'm
going to say it again because it's
important
for this example again we're all have a
hundred iq
for some of you i'm giving you some for
some i'm taking away some
we all know nobody can have 10 times our
iq well then why the hell
do people make 10 times more than we do
a thousand times more than we do
why because they think
and dream bigger than we do high
performance people
have high expectations not average
expectations
you started the hustle at about 16 did
you not
uh 14. 14. we'll go back so what were
you doing at fourteen so we moved to the
two bedroom apartment
and then i every time i took the trash
out i realized people leave stuff by the
trash can but
i'm like why is this thing next to a
dumpster you know it's a nice chair and
a table
and or a toaster so i
figured hey they probably bought a new
one they don't want it so i would you
know
haul those back to my patio you know
you're kidding me no and then by
by the weekend we've had a full patio
where the furniture
and uh we got a swap mate
we rented a space at swap made across
the street which was orange cross
college
and we started with one space and then
it turned out to be three spaces i
expanded my business you know i was 14
at 14. yeah so i used to get up early in
the morning like four in the morning and
go to all the you know dumpsters and
pick up stuff you know i
start with my own apartment complex
where we use the brand yeah then
and then i realized hey why don't we go
you know over there walk over to the
next
complex and then hey i was making you
know a thousand bucks a month
at 14 to 16 because i didn't have a work
permit yet
so that was my first business you know
picking is cost of goods is free right
so you pick up stuff and then sell swap
meet the space i think was 10 bucks a
space
to rent so it's nothing hard work i
believe that you know we're very
focused we're very focused company we
don't
really go into things that we don't
understand you know any business that i
don't
understand it well i don't do it at all
and that's really where
you know why we're successful you've
said it before that when you started out
there was a time when it was just about
money
one was just about getting rich that's
it i used to repeat that over and over
and over
what i just want to get right i just
want to get rich that's what this is i
kept saying to my wife i'm going to make
you rich i'm going to make you rich i'm
going to make you rich like
it was it was the core of my identity
from the time i was probably pre-teen
because this was tied to my desire to be
a filmmaker
was film was i knew like inside i
identify as an artist
far more than i do as an entrepreneur
and
i was looking at okay i love poetry and
i love filmmaking
well there's no money to be made in
poetry but i could become
truly wealthy in filmmaking so that for
me was a creative endeavor
that i could also generate tremendous
wealth and so that put me on a path
which of course was part of the reason
that i went into being an entrepreneur
in the first place was
i needed to control the art i needed to
control the resources so
i had to like learn business and so
going down that path and really
realizing what it took to
build a business and all of that which
is a whole universe unto itself
to have the will to push through all of
that difficulty it was i'm gonna get
rich i'm to get rich i'm going to get
rich
and then just realize that maybe for
scrooge mcduck
who wants to swim in his money that
would be like a self-sustaining
motivation
but somebody even like a warren buffett
at the end of the day
it money means something to him and it's
the thing that it
means that drives him it isn't the money
in and of itself and the problem was i
was
literally chasing money in and of itself
what i found out
is that people want to learn about money
iq which is about financial intelligence
it's about investing how to buy stocks
and how to trade
and all the other things but what i
found out is that money eq
is more important than money iq money eq
is
emotional intelligence about money how
healthy you feel
with money a healthy relationship is
that when you feel happy about money
your money eq is high when you
constantly worry about money and
you you have fear on money but your
money eq is low
and the highest money iq people
with all the mbas and all the doctor
degree
they are good at investing and they're
super good with business but these high
money iq people
often lose everything because of low
money eq
even though you built a high tower with
money iq
the foundation is shaky it's gonna fall
so money eq is a foundation of life
for example if you get a 500 raise which
is great
but can you keep the money probably
you will celebrate your race and spend
it all
and then if you get a 2 000 dollar race
which is great
probably you're going to move to a
better and bigger house
and then you're going to probably buy a
bigger car and more expenses go
up so even though you get a raise you
make more money
your expenses also are trying to match
your income
so you have no money at the end of the
month anyway
i have known many ceos who are making a
few hundred thousand dollars a year
but still they cannot keep any money
left because their lifestyle
consumes all the money so unless you
learn about money
eq and how the solid foundation
you'll never be able to feel peace with
money and you'll never be able to
achieve
true financial independence i want to
offer a cautionary tale
and again having both read your book and
also the notes that you kindly sent me
before this
if you don't understand the subtlety
here you you would conclude that the
correct thing to do is to grow
everything as fast you possibly can
everywhere
right so let's just make as many
engineers as many sales people as many
products and so on and so on
that completely does not work and it
doesn't work because no product shall
ship before it actually works
right and the way you build great
products
is you have small teams with strong
leaders
who obsess over trade-offs and they push
things off and they say we've got to get
it done and they put a lot of pressure
on the team
they work all night and they produce a
product that just barely works
okay the original used non-google
examples the original ipod
just barely worked look at what it
became try people remember the original
iphone
no apps right everyone's forgotten that
just barely worked but it just was just
the right combination
to create an enormous franchise that's
now 70 percent
of the revenue of the world's most
valuable company i was talking to travis
clonic
we are major
investors inside of uber so we have good
relations with uber
and his description of uber was that
he understood scaling but the product
the app wasn't ready
so so you have to sort of have judgment
about when the product is ready to scale
against it
and um so we would debate this over and
over again
and so larry and sugar would play tricks
on me so typical example would be
i would say we're not strong enough to
take on microsoft
and they wanted to do an operating
system in a browser and i said there's
no scenario where we'll ever do an
operating system in a browser
and because microsoft will kill us and i
don't want to get killed we're a small
company and yes yes you're very smart
and yes yes we're full of smart people
and yes yes we have lots of revenue
these guys can kill us because i'd been
previously killed in the previous jobs
and so they hired somebody to in to
improve the performance of firefox
um six months later i'm called down to
one office and
the person who is supposed to improve
the performance of firefox has managed
to invent chrome
shocking and i say well how long you've
been doing this
well i've been doing it on the side no
you haven't you've done it full time
well yeah you know what three other
people okay well how many more people do
you have oh 10 more people
well did larry okay did larry and sergey
know about this larry encouraged it i
said
that's right you know it's like i knew
it i knew they were going around me
right okay
um so and then i said well we can't do
an operating system
so they bought this company called
android and they said yeah yeah it's
just for smartphones it's software for
smartphones don't worry eric
today android is 1.4 billion 1.4 billion
plus operating systems use largest
number of operating systems in the world
chrome is the largest the most
successful browser so
maybe the lesson to learn in management
is i'm just wrong all the time
but but the secret was you sort of you
have to have judgment as to when these
things can
scale right and i can give you plenty of
negative examples
um an obvious one is wave right it was a
complicated email product
that uh we launched um to great fanfare
and we watched its adoption rate marissa
had this rule
which is a good rule that you cannot a
google you cannot tell how successful a
product is until the first six months
because what happens is you get this
adoption cycle
and everyone loves the product because
everyone tests it and then you watch
what happens
and the great products you know they're
bumpy but they go up well this is what
it looked like like this
so it took eric your friendly ceo 18
months
of going down straight down before the
project was canceled right
so again lack of due diligence last so
the the reason i'm answering your
question in the the blitz growth
argument
by saying you've got to have the
products that you can scale
if you have the products that can scale
the thing that's new is you can scale
very quickly
the uber example once you have
an app and a business model that more or
less works there's no reason why you
shouldn't go global and wide
if you want to know the five money
habits behind every rich person check
out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
i'll see you there that's what changed
the entire destiny of my family
wow was that my grandmother 30 with no
college education
working at gimble's department store
milwaukee wisconsin
[Music]